[Music]
what's up reject nation it's John come
in and check guys I'm feeling like a kid
again because this week has just been
chock-full of you know revitalized
properties from my youth we got Mary
Poppins earlier this week got Winnie the
Pooh earlier this week or Christopher
Robin I should say and now we got a
trailer for The Grinch that's right guys
cuz christmas is coming perpetually
forever because that's how time works
and that's how annual events work as
well so yeah backed out of this new
trailer I know it's by illumination who
makes like the Despicable Me and the
minions movies and stuff like that so
that has me on like an iffy ground just
because I like Despicable Me I don't
love everything about those movies but
generally speaking I appreciated their
more cartoony especially in the wake of
more poignant animated films something
like Despicable Me was kind of nice to
go back to a more zany a more cartoon
oriented vibe that being said though I
don't really know what to expect from
this I admit I haven't seen their other
Seuss movies and Lorax or horton hears a
who but
but you know I'm interested it's the
Grinch it's a classic so uh you know see
how this goes
come with me
[Music]
[Music]
marketing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
very busy I don't understand how his
body works
[Music]
[Music]
really
[Music]
huh okay at least from where I'm
standing right now I'm kind of 50/50 on
this trailer on first impression and to
be honest I don't love the Jim Carrey
movie and I grew up on and I grew up on
the classic sort of hand-drawn animated
one with Boris Karloff and and Thurl
Ravenscroft and I feel like based on
this this probably is gonna fall in
between those for me this looks more
appealing to me oddly enough than the
Jim Carrey one and you know I just have
such a soft spot for that original win
the trailer started I couldn't help but
roll my eyes just because I get the
contrast like using --happy is funny cuz
the Grinch is not happy and the whole
arc of his characters that he learns how
to love and be happy and stuff like that
but it just felt intrusive like I get it
Despicable Me you guys did there's
already a minion in your bumper like I
don't need that personally the rest of
this you know I I did get a definite
Despicable Me vibe when he's like at the
store and stuff and the choice to make
it so that he's just kind of out among
the who's already it doesn't seem as
he's as remote as maybe the original
story had him being which could be cool
the stuff I like the most about this
trailer is aside from the happy moment
everything in the cave between the
Grinch and Max and that's the stuff that
kind of convinced me that maybe this
could be pretty charming pretty fun and
brings some of that more lively more
energetic cartoon like quality to this
so um you know not my favorite of the
throwback trailers I've seen this week
but it also gave me a couple things to
look forward to so yeah I think this
looks alright and I'm interested to see
how it shapes up you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get updated every time a review
or a video is out hit us up on the
Stardust app link in the description box
as well as viewer reviews commlink in
the box and as always guys you stay
crunchy Cheers
you